[Music]
ah
yes the beasting king and the rat king
[Music]
is it really yeah wayne's world wild i
think i was one years old
ah you were in wayne's world bro uh-uh
you weren't no i wasn't
me dude we had a guy actually by us this
kid named wayne king right and he
couldn't read
wayne king i don't know if he could read
but if he could read he wasn't
he wasn't admitting it sure and he used
to when he couldn't
express himself they had a wooden fence
like this huge long wooden fence behind
the apartment
he'd run right [ __ ] through it to get
his point across like if he was real
serious and he made a point though
a hundred percent yeah like if he you
knew
what was going on with him did he get
all the chicks
no no no no he didn't i i never saw him
with a shirt on and i and he was jacked
we had titties um he was jacked up like
something was
he he had
i guess he had ted he's kind of how old
was he his father was a bus driver his
father never wore a shirt
milford king was his father has the bus
driver yeah damn that's frowned upon bro
that's when you got some new orleans
[ __ ] that's not frowned upon depends on
where you're at apparently you grew up
in the shirt belt where everybody has
shirts dude
yeah man if you're driving kids you
gotta have your clothes on bro
out dude speaking of church you're also
wearing a large from uh disneyland
me bro children's law oh you look like a
college kid i mean you got
blue one that was given to you got a
purple [ __ ]
skinny sweats on these are plum those
are very purple bro
these aren't purple dudes you look like
you're transitioning and ran out of
money
[Laughter]
you look like you look like a russian
spy who's transitioning
but they don't know exactly how it works
in [ __ ]
america so they give us this
you know [ __ ] anyone bro what about uh
[ __ ] king of things
[Applause]
hummus is middle eastern i know you're
the shitty freshman
ever you're a shitty transitioning
russian spy bro
dude no doubt you look like every gay
dude that's about to teach a dance
lesson on television that's exactly what
you look like right now i'll take that
you got that blood gold watch dude how
many brothers
how many black men and probably black
children had to die so you could have
that watch
i don't know man i don't know bro very
smart diamonds
if you put it up tomorrow but i can hear
the mayflower coming over with a bunch
of straight-ups
i'm just saying that you go in that
direction i wouldn't wear that kind of
stuff man no it's not it's not for you
bro it's not for your kind
yeah then that's being that's being cool
okay should we kick this off or what man
yeah man it's been kicked um
it's been kicked yeah you lead it man
you're gonna sprinkle tell them about
the sprinkles sir people talking about
the spreckels
yeah talk about the sprackles yeah first
of all he's talking about sprackles
don't say i'm performing at spreckels
theater thus freckles theater
thus whatever dude you know who the
spreckels were no
first of all delicious no family of
dwarfs that grew fruit
actually near santa ana that makes sense
oh beautiful tangerines
yeah all right and dude what made them
so beautiful is they had to
all stack up into like a human pyramid
yeah so it's teamwork so really the
definition of teamwork actually yeah and
speaking of teamwork i'm gonna be at
spreckels theater bro but alone but
you're performing by yourself right by
myself
yeah yeah no there's no the first
one-hour special yeah what's it called
do you know
uh you'd be surprised wow you'd be
surprised huh
you know what that's off of it's a play
from uh when i started doing stand-up
when joe rogan goes
uh we he gave me that talk and then i
said i think you'd be surprised
because we're talking about fighting
when you're quitting fighting yep oh wow
from that and he said you think i think
you
yeah i said i think you'd be surprised
wow this name is special you'd be
surprised i like it man
thanks doug well you're gonna be in
irvine that night huh you're gonna be in
irvine yeah i'll be in irvine all that
weekend so
and the sprinkles is almost sold out
isn't it yeah so super close
so unless you want to stand outside in
the cold it's going to be colder over
there
you'd be surprised you can still get a
ticket to see me in irvine
you'd be surprised you can still see fee
on irvine
so dang i didn't even know it though huh
turbine's dope oh it's going to be good
man it's going to be fun
um have you done breyer yet yeah since
they redid it i love brandon since they
redid it though
oh yeah i mean i've done bray i'm just
saying they redid it yeah it's
supposed to be right up there with
irvine now huge it's bigger than irvine
really yeah
dude um you know hit me up actually
bisping hit me up and said he's going to
come out to irvine oh nice that'd be
pretty cool
he lives in orange county yeah he lives
down there yeah you see that video of
him and his son on instagram him driving
with his son on his lap
no i didn't see it it's pretty cool man
yeah it's like a cool father-son moment
um
yeah he's a good dude all right well
let's get into this dude the
long-awaited
this is the first trial episode we want
to get you guys feedback and get into
this
we're going to work out the kinks figure
it out king or stinger baby dude i'll
sting those socks very you see those
yeah what's up
what's up bro i feel like they go with
your outfit man dude how many fraggles
had to die so you could [ __ ] have a
little bit of sauce
how many muppet babies had to die to
make this thing dude
dang covering up your miss piggies bro
what's up bro
all right let's get your sting so if we
like it we're going to king it
if we don't like it we're going to sting
it wow can't slip one by this [ __ ]
cavalry
cat you got to let the audience know bro
and i gotta let you know that haircut
doesn't exactly scream i got a degree
from
you you're here right now what's up bro
what's up bro
oh my god i'll have a second scoop of
yams please
all right okay all right
okay definitely that is cafeteria grade
hair
right there cafeteria lady here
piccadilly bro
go here's the first one from breasty
jeff
what's up phyllis theo oh i know this
guy
jeff what up brother
i drive that truck right there and
i'm trying to rock this and i got the
tuxedo
the canadian tuxedo going on texas texas
i wanted to uh king it or sting it
uh anal pleasures oh wow uh with your
tongue
what'd you guys think wow that's gonna
start off with something
coming out hot he looks like a dude
who's into s
play though isn't he i mean he
definitely you don't grow that
that that tail out if you're not no you
don't wear a full
jay leno outfit without licking ass yeah
without buying a bunch of expensive cars
you know what i'm saying yeah i think
he's lying saying he's 27 but that's for
another thing
if he's 27 i'm 22. i know breasty jeff
he uh
what are they calling breasty jeff he he
has breasts he got woman's breasts it's
called gynoplasty
and he has woman's breasts on a man's
cage hold up is it from
because did he do a bunch of steroids he
has gyno and then got the
breast removed or did he put in implants
because he's transitioning i don't know
what do you know anything more about it
i think he's got that gynecomastia but i
don't think it was from steroids he's
had it since he was a child oh wow yeah
that can be a case too
if you let another kid suck on your tits
too when you're young it can make it
happen yeah if they do it like multiple
times a week
i've seen that but it makes your body
think that you're going to have to
support a kid
but um anyway ass yeah so anal pleasures
with your tongue
got it it it's for me it's case by case
man you got to be
fresh out the shower bro yeah i mean you
have to be fresh
out of a you almost have to be come out
of a fire and they hosed you down really
really good right in front of me with
like
that crisp garden hose you can't be that
detroit water i need that fresh [ __ ]
yeah i need that evian and i'll have a
little bit of butt i'll have you know
i'm not having a lot no it's not my
thing if i'm eating ass i'm not having
a lot no it's not my thing like you know
i'm having a small
size you know what i'm saying it's my
cranberry dressing because thanksgiving
dinner you know yeah i'll have a little
you know i have a tea food i ain't
having half a cup so down there having
half a cup or a little quart
some dudes are all ass really yeah yeah
i
had a girl one time pin my legs back
like a baby and just go
straight for the bunny hole disgusted me
really
dude that's like that's like that kid in
your like when you have a friend come
over and they won't stop looking for
your christmas gifts at your parents oh
the worst bro give it a break
yeah don't ruin my christmas there's
always something
some [ __ ] kid that was doing that and
he put on a bandana and stuff and take
his shirt off and try to look for all
your presents
like a burglar and that reminds me of
that kind of girl like that yeah she's
down for that too i bet
yeah man i think if it comes to that
kind of stuff unless somebody's drug
mulen
i'm not trying to eat something out of
her butt no me neither that's another
thing
i'm gonna say sting it yeah i'm gonna
say sting it too it's a hard sting too
like yeah i'll have a little bro but i
ain't having a lot you know exactly i'll
talk you know
i'll see what's going on but i ain't
[ __ ] milling around nah
you know i'll stop by the party but i
ain't gonna be the last one there no i'm
out
yeah so sting that yeah sting that uh
number two
is perfect for christmas time it's from
anthony frederick
hey what's up guys this is anthony from
nebraska dana white i don't know if you
can see way back behind me there's a
giant penguin with a santa claus hat on
his head
i'm not putting up my christmas lights
and i thought of a question for you
king hit or sting it inflatable
christmas decorations
there's what behind them there's a
penguin with a hat on
and then big ass inflatable things
it's so much work and effort to do that
[ __ ] i like christmas
lights but when you go overboard and you
got the big santa the and the reindeers
and [ __ ] yeah
not for me bro really nah you seem like
that kind of guy
though oh i do christmas lights you
don't do the extras you get you drive
that car that it's like a damn
you know it's that smooth buggy it's
that are you talking about the
three-wheeler dude they just sent one of
those to mars i thought the other day
oh man see an alien just cruising around
saturn in that the rover bro
yeah the mars rover broke things out
there send back the
images bro we were waiting on these
images no we paid 70 billion
[ __ ] images for a couple of [ __ ]
images when you grow up did
did since your parents gonna afford
those did this put you in the lawn you
and your brother you're swinging like
this
while you guys were holding lights and
[ __ ] like this
happy holidays from the vaughn's dude we
had a guy that got electrocuted in our
neighborhood and that kind of held us
all over for about a decade
um he was doing his own christmas lights
and it was raining at the same time and
he was trying to do like a big finale or
whatever
you got to do it man and uh yeah and he
had that got passed away that was pretty
violent i think he actually got hit by
lightning
but um that'll put a damper on you oh
that really christmas that shut it down
and it happened right by the chimney up
on the
on the building so everybody was like
smoking well it was just saying it like
ruined the whole thing for everybody was
like [ __ ] there's a dead guy right by
the chimney
anyone think it was actually santa no i
don't think that
somebody mighta maybe wayne with that
shirt dude but when were the shirt off
freezing yeah
if he was if he had an idea he'd run
right through a [ __ ] fence bro
he didn't know how to express himself
you know yeah except by taking down you
know
latticework but i would say i'm not
opposed to it i'm not like
anti-christmas but when you see it if
you drive by it in a neighborhood
if it's well done don't give me the
[ __ ] like you got to put some effort
into it yeah every now and then they'll
throw in a grimace they had a dude in
our neighborhood he would paint
like the ones from halloween he'd then
paint them for christmas budget cuts bro
no you can't do that you can't get the
good will version of that [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying
like you got to put up the real thing
yeah you can go all out go all out
don't put up a caveman a penguin and
[ __ ]
santa claus you know what i'm saying
yeah yeah don't put a couple steve
buscemi's out there
this dude put a ghost out there one year
it was like married
ghost of christmas get the [ __ ] out of
my face bro
unless it's a reindeer yeah those things
are a little too big
i think uh i saw one guy just put his
dogs out front bro really yeah left him
in the snow
oh wow yeah and put uh antlers on him oh
dang that's kind of cool
yeah i've seen that before i could see
that if you put some lights i like the
manger
you know somebody would always put a
manger up but then people would spray
paint like all kinds of profanity on it
you know like i'd [ __ ] mary somebody
wrote on god
damn that's vicious jesus man
you know so what do you think king or
sting it i'm going to say
sting it man it's too much i think it's
just you're wanting too much attention
and it the lights are the magic if you
do the lights you're doing something
good i'm cool with the i'm with you i'm
cool on the lights
yeah you just you do trying too hard man
yeah they had one they found a homeless
dude living in somebody's inflatable too
makes sense man they look comfy as [ __ ]
yeah warm yeah always on
already built yeah big colorful almost
like an igloo yeah yeah
yeah so sting that [ __ ] yeah all right
number three this comes from a recent
conversation
i believe brendan had on a fight
companion
what up guys my name is alexis from
middleton texas play this phone line i'm
just trying to become a member of yours
extravagant hair club
damn bro but uh i got a king
inter-stinger
king and they're stinging at chocolate
bodies uh congratulations to both you
guys on the upcoming podcast
and i hope you guys do great onward
thanks brother them chocolate bodies
he's talking about africans
no bro no bro he's talking about
bodybuilders who
decide to paint their bodies chocolate
to look more ripped like the black guys
oh yeah but they leave their face or
they leave their hands and their feet
everyone's doing it man it's a hard pack
it's so racist and no one's brought it
up oh wow and it's everywhere bro
someone sent me a picture of uh in japan
as bodybuilding competition
they did just their lower body oh yeah
just the lower half
chocolate body chocolate bottom
chocolate booty that chocolate booty
chocolate dunk
people are doing dyeing their bodies
yeah so they look more real like look at
this [ __ ]
oh god dude since when did we approve
them
yeah they dipped them in tanning
solution he asked for it
but we're but if someone now if he went
just chocolate face
i mean it's [ __ ] it's ridiculous yeah
people you you're gonna get [ __ ]
torched
but you can go chocolate bottom we act
like it's all good oh wow
look at that bro see i think the guy
looks better on the left
oh 100 it doesn't even look realistic it
looks like a martian
it makes zero sense no one wants to
address it we're shouldn't give him the
free pass
no hell no i thought he's a if you would
rather have a black body or a white body
oh black body all day you would yeah
yeah black bodies are like the
lamborghinis a body you show up in a
black body they're always shredded for
the most part
yeah they're always lean you know what
i'm saying cats dude they had a black
baby the other day born with like seven
tats
you can't even see him yeah like he
could have a full body oh yeah
buff tats you have no idea it looks
cooler on them why dudes tattoos stick
out more
but why do i say this black guy get an
erection or a latino guy get an erection
all the same color hard to see let's see
white white guy gets that little red
freaking firing rod
almost like a dark room yeah yeah that
thing's raring to go
and that's purple head too yeah yeah
maroon shaft purple head
you know it's go time oh that's that
[ __ ] vietnamese [ __ ] night stick
yeah
that's that [ __ ] thai iced tea baby
but black guy sometimes a black guy
surprise you every now and then it'll
pop up my porno
selection be like suggestions for you
and i'll see this black dick
that thing looks like a goddamn
measuring stick of different colors it
looks like crayola [ __ ]
coloring book bro but imagine that
here's my thing is black guys with the
big dicks like
haven't you been through enough carrying
around a big dick all the time
it reminds me almost it makes me think
of like indentured servants or a long
time ago
you think it's exhausting yeah yeah it's
like jesus with the cross
yeah and it's like put it down just give
them a break
yeah but they can right they can't dude
and also black eyes are going to be
stronger than white guys because they're
carrying
you know an extra pound between their
legs yeah it's like every day
it's like if a white guy put on ankle
weights all his life they just wake up
like that
bro but i don't like this inner the
crossing of the different you know like
when people start getting i mean i don't
know when you dye your body brown to
look better at a dance competition what
is it
bodybuilding competition they've been
doing it forever too yeah because
like a dude like ronnie coleman show up
who's [ __ ] jacked and chocolate and
you know because is he really black yeah
you can see the definition their muscle
better when you're darker so the white
guy went
[ __ ] this noise i'm gonna paint my body
black you ain't getting an advantage on
me
and we just give them the free pass and
i'm here to say
but you want to roast [ __ ] rachel
dozell you've seen her
yeah yeah you want to raise yeah i think
she's done all great she went full
chocolate body no one gives he tried to
help the community
yeah it's jesus christ i don't ever
wants to [ __ ] lynch that poor lady
black better i know 2 000 black ladies
look like her that ain't doing [ __ ] i
know but when you get sometimes you get
a crossover like
i don't know but if a white dude but if
a black dude did white body
yeah we wouldn't give a [ __ ] people are
blurring too much these days anyway i
you know or it's good that they're
blurring but it's con it's still
confusing sometimes yeah i thought you
were black for the longest really
yeah i thought you were a light skinned
black dude oh i could see that yeah with
like your nose and lips
oh wow i know i was like oh there he is
i was going to say because of my
positive [ __ ] you know vibrant
attitude and
that too bro but it's i didn't know i
didn't know
yeah dude wow that's crazy i think we
sting the [ __ ] out of
chocolate bodies though yeah think it's
frowned upon bodies it's just giving
people the wrong impression
you know um but i could see somebody
going black body if you want to roll up
to the basketball court's black body
paint yourself so you get picked glass
no you can get back pick first that's
what i'm saying because if you're white
dude you roll
up you're probably getting picked last
you can pick last night every time well
unless you're like
john stockton can shoot pass some [ __ ]
and that guy got picked last
until he proved himself yeah and shout
out to ed mccaffrey the only white
player still in the nfl
well his son's in the nfl but yeah is he
really yeah his son's a baller shout out
to eddie jr
no christian mccaffrey bro what else you
got what's going on rat king
and the beast don't mind the hurt
on my lips
uh pit bulls king it
or sting it baby oh he's hitting that
jewel
oh [ __ ] son vape away bro get that herp
off your lip for the next time we see
you though yeah clean your jewel buddy
come on bro you could have waited a week
before you [ __ ] did the video and had
herpes on your lips oh he had that that
[ __ ] happens though bro he hit that's
right like your booty hole [ __ ] doesn't
happen no he probably king booty holding
people that have herpes yeah correct
that dude
happened vernon's like oh man i have
this aids flare up today
yeah you got aids all the time yeah
that's life bro
but dude if you start groundhog i got a
buddy and he's like sometimes you can't
even hear him he's got so many sores on
his mouth ah damn bro he goes in the
sunshine they all come out they're like
groundhog
oh just all over his lips they're body
ground they're basically like having a
little groundhog
he looks like one of the sucker fish on
the fish tanks yeah look at that right
there
dude he looks like one of those yeah the
suckerfish that cleaned the tank
yeah it looked like you've been sucking
dick at like a chemical plant or
something non-stop though like a glory
hole at a chemical plant
and then you're gonna have a lot of
exactly anyway that's what i'm thinking
yeah
uh pit bulls this is a big king of baby
pit bulls i [ __ ] love pimples i grew
up with one
i had i've had three of them really yeah
i grew up with a pit bull named spud
oh it's like spot mckenzie yeah oh
that's cool i love pimples
well here's the thing about pitbulls
though man what people don't think about
is
they said that pit bulls don't have
dreams they only have nightmares while
they're sleeping that makes sense
does that make sense so my thing is is
that their fault though
i mean they're doing it i'm thinking
oh pitbull the yeah we talking about
pitbull the animal people
people the singer can [ __ ] kick rocks
yeah he looks like william shatner's
blind son
is one of the probably six or seven most
all the songs sound exactly the same
it's crazy
oh [ __ ] that guy but pimples i love
people dogs
they're good until athletic people are
scared of them
and they're friendly as [ __ ] they're
just dog aggressive well they don't like
other dogs or babies once a year in
florida they bite a baby's face off in
florida so if you want to play that
lottery
take your chances yeah they're great
they're great with kids though man i'm
telling you
but then they're suddenly not great with
kids and they go they go back to being
great
you know what pimples are like
especially if you adopt them which i did
it's like having a best friend who was a
former felon
like you see that like he's trying to do
better but you don't trust him fully
you know george what's his name the
comedian yeah like you can't trust him
fully you know he's like a bad dude
but under the right circumstances he's
all right yeah
you can't bring them to dog parks
everyone freaks the [ __ ] out they do oh
dude
yeah man when i was doing rap videos so
you look cool chicks dig them well poor
people always had when i was young for
some reason it was like a poor people's
dog yeah pitbulls and rottweilers i
guess because people
didn't have like alarm systems so you'd
see more of that activity correct
but i would never go near one probably i
used to do
drugs and stuff with this man named
billy conforto actually he was
homosexual or homoerotic
sure and he we used to be bus boys even
though he was in his 40s
but he um and he actually died
eventually he drove into an embankment
on some pills
committed suicide i don't know or it was
just pretty brave i bet he just tried it
yeah he thought he could like go through
yeah or just maybe if i was like back to
the future and thought he was going to
go through the wall and just
it's real life so it didn't work out
that way well that's hot yeah they call
drugs are a hell of a drug
they call it drugs or a hell of a hell
of a drug well he um
but anyway we were talking about oh he
had a bunch of pimples and i'd go over
there and get high
and then he'd let them all loose in the
room and i'd be so scared how old were
they
were the pit bulls different ages
probably but were they friendly though
because usually if they're
if they're friendly they're great if
they're in the wrong hands they're the
worst dog you have
they were i think they they really
scared me he used to train him in the
yard he put these things up and they
would jump and get him like 10 feet in
these were you training to be fighting
dogs yeah he was training
oh [ __ ] yeah bad dude it was dangerous
yeah that's dangerous you don't want to
be in there with them
uh i say king pit bulls sounds like
you've had a bad experience with him
i've had a bad experience but you have
had more experience i'm going to ride
with you on this one
all right baby king all right number
five from
this guy's really intense funk roberts
oh god an asian
what's up what's up guys my name is funk
roberts from toronto canada i do online
fitness for men over 40 and strength
conditioning for
fighters my king it or sting it is
nude volleyball tournaments naked
volleyball tournaments during the early
2000s i used to go to
the super bowl of volleyball nude
volleyball naked volleyball at white
thorn lodge
um 1500 naked people from newborns all
the way to
people that are 99 years old and all
shapes and sizes i've seen it all but
would you guys do
naked volleyball yeah
damn he's jacked he looks like the kind
of dude who's in the naked volleyball
i met that guy actually i'm gonna call
it i met that guy
at a show backstage in
um uh
uh toronto do you spike a ball in your
face naked
no him and his wife man he dates this
little white uh this little white
firefly lady and they're like yeah their
strength and conditioning
here's the thing and i'll go straight
into you funk um shout out to funk bro
yeah shout out to phone shout out to the
funk
yeah the naked funk dude that how how
naked do you think he was in that did
how low did these show in the video he
had sweats on i think
dude that wasn't sweats bro that's a
huge flat cotton [ __ ]
let's check it out again maybe his [ __ ]
had a drawstring
maybe just his dick had an outfit on
oh [ __ ] oh boy shred okay okay yeah he's
jeans on
his jeans already in that prison outfit
it could be a top of a denim diaper you
can't see much i keep shred city though
well here's the thing i'll say this
first guy to get their nuts caught in
the net it's over bro and that's gonna
happen
standard bro or first chick to get her
titties caught up in the net
you got some big old knockers you go up
just [ __ ] spike the ball
come down tits game over dude game over
why are you playing it naked first of
all why can't you play
regular [ __ ] volleyball why you gotta
have your tits and dick out yeah
yeah and also if it's i'm assuming it's
saying volleyball
if you dive and my dick [ __ ] takes a
nose plant into the [ __ ] sand
ah no hell no not for me man
that's so that's such a that's like an
old like
[ __ ] sand is an old school thing you
know that's what they did back in the
desert probably egypt or something early
you know probably first 10 chapters in
the bible if you
think about the background of it you
know there's probably people out there
doing [ __ ] dirt i feel like we've
evolved we don't need to play in the
sand anymore
right now i see the idea going back now
funk though it looks like i mean he's a
strong guy what if a
uh unstrapping or some setter gets out
there just setting the ball all day
you know and then funk just has his [ __ ]
in your face spiking the ball
just spike oh think about the the trauma
you're gonna go through
later that night if you got funk in that
dark
knight dick in your face nonstop round
after round
round after round i mean you can just
imagine it once if you want to
god he's he's spiking that dick in your
face all night long baby yeah you could
just imagine it
one time and no it ain't gonna be once
you be in there all night long
tim might even touch your lip you don't
even have it but no i i don't think that
but i do imagine him doing a pele style
thing where he's able to spike
tomorrow he spins over and hits his dick
first
yeah like a black like the movie black
panther yeah
yeah dude and that's the thing i'm gonna
get i would not watch that
yeah and what kind of chicks are gonna
be i mean if you got some hot chicks
coming out there
how many dudes is that this thing funk i
think here's my thing if we're all
playing
and they're hot chicks like they have
them apple bottoms and tits out
yeah you're gonna let me rock hard baby
rock hard i can't hide this thing like
funk can't
i can't i can't oh this is my mic oh
this is my tail no
not for me i get a [ __ ] rock hard
boner
i don't get a lot of boners outdoors i'm
more of an i can't get erect outdoors
anymore i can't get her wrecked near
broken glass those are like my two
cavities that's your [ __ ]
yeah even even if there's a good wind
gust oh
dude i can't [ __ ] stay hard if the
air conditioning's on and it's
is the sound i think it's a cold air
you know because i feel like winter's
coming i got to prepare that makes sense
but my thing is for for this guy font
uh font roberts naked volleyball
i'm going to say sting it man i i don't
think we need it
i'm with them i don't think we need
sting it but funk do your thing
i celebrate you doing it yeah that fat
dick but for us it's a stinging and he
may have had a small dick now that's no
no funk you don't name yourself funk get
shredded have that beard
talk about naked that [ __ ] said
and i've been going for a while you
don't show up with a small dick to make
it volleyball there you go
you bring in the heat that's true bring
that heater show up and funk's just
bouncing the ball on his [ __ ] over in
the corner
like yeah like it's like a clock
he's just there he's the [ __ ] time
keeper like this
dude he sneaks up on people while
they're waiting and he just sets it on
their shoulder and tells him that it's a
snake or or if you uh stepped over the
line or something like that he hit you
on the shoulder with his dick like
nah man not up in here like he's the ref
that's his dick
all right what else sting it i'm sorry
yes
sting it bro shout out to funk though
last one for king and the sting from
frankie beedle
let's see frank oh wow all right frank
my name's frankie beedle what's up tom's
a girl
from nevada definite hitman yeah
king of her stinger baby dead body my
trunk what should i do with bologna
nipples
with the baloney nipple like talking
about the big nipples like the saucers
like the pepperoni dollars can you pull
one up i can't legally look at them on
my computer i have blockers on there
right now
yeah i don't want virus either on my
phone oh
like the big old uh
oh i could go for some more adela maybe
oh [ __ ] is that nick jonas with them big
ass nibs
nick jones got some pepperoni nipples
somebody's got him
somebody got him i don't know too many
people with him oh
[ __ ] son that girl that uh that girl is
poor
poison check out those that's the face
turn this off and i'm not allowed to
look at this i think this is the most
i can't look at this kind of stuff okay
sorry man
um you want me to tell your sponsor no
should we not talk about sexual [ __ ] we
can talk about it i just
know not a lot of looking not that
graphically i can look at
you're not allowed to look at porno and
[ __ ] yeah ever
i mean i can look at it sponsors it but
then i can also never have a family or
be married and just jack off at night by
myself at home
yeah yeah yeah all right then let's not
have you look at porn because i don't
want your movie to end that way no i can
talk thank you
i can talk about it some but i don't
want to do that but here's what i'm
saying is baloney nipples first of all
this guy's sitting in his car thinking
about bunny devils now first of all
he has baloney nipples and that's why
he's asking because he's like
hey bro a quick question for you because
probably on a daze like
blowing nipples they're [ __ ] badass
right what do you guys think
you can't understand uh nipples and be
cool like it's definitely his oh there's
a dodge viper's a [ __ ]
yeah bro get them nips out bro it looks
like you some titties on you
i'm not mad at that if you got tits and
they're big like that you're going to
stick out more
and i think these days you could get a
tattoo get some cheese next to them and
like a little thing of a little
knife and you know make it like a cheese
plate on your oh you could do that or
you could get real creative and do like
mickey mouse ears like there's a bunch
of fun stuff you could do yeah
offended kids but also like i think if
you got
meat on your chest you know that's you
know that to me is like
unique yeah like there's definitely a
kind of girl you know a real italian a
girl it's a hundred percent italian
with her mouth of water when she sees
that [ __ ] cause she'll think of she'll
look at your tits and think of pepperoni
pizza yeah and she wants to suck on them
and then next thing you know she's stuck
on your titties she's bored with that
she goes down to that little [ __ ]
cannoli you got down there oh wow yeah
bro that's how it starts
tell you got some glorious hidden meats
yeah baby
uh i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna king
the pepperoni nipples because
hey you can't pick them god goes you
know what you get some big ass nips good
luck with this
same with dick size oh dude trust me man
i'm erect right now honestly
i bet after because you haven't seen
porn for a little bit and then you saw
that
you were like this turn it off
turn it off well not a house started
salivating and chilling god damn turn
that [ __ ] off there quick that's the
problem dude i'm fully arrested right
now though look like that
oh damn bro you think i'm lying
it's like prison break in this [ __ ] she
the [ __ ]
naked lady in a [ __ ] grip nick you
knew he struggles with this
why you gotta make my man get a boner
and then lie down
sweat i don't lie when i get them son
bro where are those sweats
a strip club bust your nut in a second
they ride in that [ __ ] [ __ ]
that cockatoo and them little boy sweats
you know bust all over that barry
sanders jersey
bro i'm going wichita falls on this
thing he's out of wichita you know that
um i'll say this that if you got
pepperoni nipples or any type of meaty
cheese
you know i had a buddy and he had a um
like a rare dick that was like
you remember those string cheese things
what do you mean it looked exactly like
a string
it was it was thin very thin and kind of
square and flat at the end like a
twizzler
yeah kind of like a twizzler but without
the grooves on the side you know
without the grooving so i think if you
have a unique penis that it's something
you can put like
you know that grilled cheese jesus that
came out or something like that you
could make a special instagram that's
what i'm saying
peacock with it bro yeah fancy nipples
peacock yeah
and don't be ashamed of it like that
goes back to gynoplasty my buddy ghana
uh jeff breasty jeff he had he got all
these special tattoos
bro it went down kind of it's still
[ __ ]
why am i [ __ ] down there bro because
bro you're letting these
tiny sweats and your dicks [ __ ] tiny
are you [ __ ] me and they're plumb
all right bro i'm just saying yeah you
all right now don't look down and i can
focus
look at your dick in my face bro i know
if this is prison you'd be [ __ ]
probably look at
literally literally yeah no you get
[ __ ] for looking at somebody's dick
you looking at somebody's dating no me
i'm pretty you've never been a princess
you're [ __ ] bro yeah i have been
where'd you go pelican bay oh pelican
bay bro
you [ __ ] pelican bay the resort club
the prison with the sailing team you
heard a pelican
it's a terrible prison bro what they
were the worst oh pelican bait where
they asked me again bro if we can order
ice cream ask me again bro with the
slippers ask me again yeah where did you
go to prison alcatraz
he thought alcatraz was a game the other
day he goes dude let's play that game
i'm like what game is like
you know alcatraz and i'm like that's
yahtzee and [ __ ]
people thought alcatraz was actually san
francisco
that was the capital of san francisco
well they should lock a lot of those up
yeah they should bro but um anyway you
can lock them in them sweat
you go near a school i'm already locked
up dude how [ __ ] hot is it in here
yeah it's like someone broke the
thermometer what a [ __ ] creep
uh you're hot because you got a raging
boner so i'm gonna say to homeboy here
with the
fat nips i'm gonna say king it bro rock
your nipples
you got titties peacock them titties
chicks are gonna dig it you get cannoli
sucked yeah that's true man go out there
and get a meaty broad a lady that likes
a sandwich you know hang out around
jimmy john's or something when there's
go to a subway do and see who wears a
foot long
yeah and then come up behind like hit
her with that turkey tom yeah yeah
be like you down for meatballs yeah you
want some meatballs with that
foot long but okay calm down a and show
us the deal next time if you got nipples
or something show us one of them
come in here that's what i'm saying if
you got fat nips show them on there
don't leave it to our imagination
yes apparently it gives deal a boner
well look i mean i do
i appreciate the boner appreciate the
blood flow and the crazy thing about me
is i only have a select amount of blood
in my body so if i fee
you feel dizzy oh i can feel the blood
going down all the color of your face
come yeah
i saw you lose color but that's when
you're equalized i'm fully equalized
good for you man uh king the fat nips
what else
time for debate club debate club what's
up son pick a side son all right let's
see what we got though
we definitely will have something bro
another one perfect for holiday time
from andrew barker
howdy king and sting the name's andrew
barker
i'm a 24 year old american thoroughbred
out of beaverton oregon
hilarious in search of a career that i'm
passionate for
and anyways i was wondering if you guys
could debate the topic of halloween or
christmas
i appreciate the time guys oh my god
the guy's hilarious it's like watching
comedy have you seen that
before you know it you've done 2 000
squats
before you even sweating oh dude i had
to [ __ ] go get i had to get a
protein shake at the middle of his set
the other day that was a heart rate
monitoring assassin chips and
calories he burns he would be the
funnest actually if he put
a um what's one of the uh things you do
like this on
the are you talking about the the the
[ __ ] what is that elliptical
no um this thing what's this yeah what
is this
um i don't know what the [ __ ] is this
that's the elliptical bro do it right
that's well this is the elliptical this
you're talking about this yeah
you don't know about that you don't know
you're wearing they're gonna wait bro
you don't know
your weight this are you [ __ ] bass
brothers from the wwf
what's this thing you do when you're in
the gym
dude some people run arms first you run
with your arms by your side bro
like somebody like a [ __ ] have you
ever had a crime
i'm just an honest question have you
ever ran before yeah you have i don't
know
yeah i don't know you don't look like a
guy would run oh i'm definitely right
i've never seen you move quick
ever and ever that yeah dude well this
building you can't see how quick i'm
moving this building that makes sense
it's dark in there's thick
um what was it guys halloween or
christmas halloween at christmas
what are you what are you taking on this
brother i'm taking a hard
hard case on halloween by a long [ __ ]
why because halloween is dope you can
dress up what the [ __ ] you want
chicks give it gives them an excuse to
dress up like
hookers for a night you drink with your
buddies
it's not so family oriented you know
what i'm saying christmas
you got a fake dude who's into kids
supposedly comes around
jumping from [ __ ] chimney to chimney
which is full of [ __ ]
and he comes down drops off presents so
that's all fake
halloween some real [ __ ] dude i can have
fun with my friends
dress up [ __ ] chicks with my friends
dress up
first of all you can [ __ ] chicks anytime
you want okay you don't have to wait
till one night of the year when there's
a full moon
and half your buddies are [ __ ]
drinking that sounds like the gayest
low-key game yeah but think about all
the dope scary
movies you watch on halloween what's the
best christmas movie you can watch
elf white christmas there's not too
[ __ ] many
nightmares before christmas jacks off on
all those stupid christmas no it doesn't
first of all
don't jack off and think that makes it
all better amistad is good around
christmas what else hotel rwanda
for christ passion for christ easy um
sometimes you know my family would have
sit around and look at a drawing or
picture of jesus and just light candles
okay jesus was born on christmas that's
fake that's a lot you talking about this
fake holiday
jesus christ that's fake he was not born
on christmas yeah he was nope i'm
educating the [ __ ] out of you okay well
he's not born on christmas what do you
want christmas
made up holiday nope was not born they
think his birthday was around august or
8th who's it
they dude the world bro the [ __ ]
world yeah it's fake bro he was not born
on christmas
christmas holidays you're a [ __ ]
eddie bravo right now this is not a
conspiracy look it up you're
the 11th when was jesus christ born when
was jesus
uh the earliest source saying 25th as
they did like 20th yeah don't read that
fast the part we need
the earliest things that took place at
the spring equinox so he went and worked
out at equinox okay which he placed on
25th of march where's the 25th of march
is that off of la cienega
yeah right around there and first of all
you can't
christmas bro you get to decorate
everyone's full of joy
people yeah or depression but people get
each other
gifts bro what responsibility do you
have on halloween
zero to get your dick out eat candy you
can do that if you want
you can do that on easter we gotta get
each other gifts and [ __ ] yeah there's a
lot of responsibility
you gotta wrap it you know yeah dude but
yeah but that's part of the joy showing
other people joy
at christmas you get to they have tinsel
you can put tinsel on your friend
at christmas you can have hot cocoa at
christmas you can be outside and then it
gets cold and you have to go back inside
that [ __ ] isis eggnog i've never had
eggnog so
good oh bro it's like yeah it's like
having a [ __ ] omelette with cinnamon
in it and not having to eat it you get
to pour it right down your house
dude eggnog you should be on my side
right away
you can hook up with your mom's friends
on christmas oh you can't halloween you
can bro
how do christmas old women wear brooches
and you get to be like oh that looks
nice
you could wear assless chaps if you want
yeah that's halloween man no
come on bro halloween think about all
the dope ass halloween movies
dude halloween yeah people get murdered
at all the halloween movies
friday the 13th friday the 14th
nightmare on
elm street um [ __ ] uh
goonies friday friday afternoon
friday after next black friday dennis
society minutes to society it's all
about murder dude oh dude halloween
you know so i'm just saying halloween is
a time where there's a lot of fear
people are scared
ghosts people stand up doing coke you
know
you [ __ ] i remember hooking up with
some girl that was a ladybug
you know indefinitely yeah one one time
my brother dressed up as a penguin
yes my brother dressed up as a penguin
we're at a party a bunch of other dudes
showed up at penguins he fought him he
didn't like that they copped his style
so there's a whole penguin you're not
getting a penguin fight on christmas
no no one dresses the [ __ ] up if you
believe that
what i'm talking about is christmas dude
christmas is the one time of year
when you can tell somebody you love them
and not even really give a [ __ ]
yeah if you got problems yeah been in
therapy since you were 12. you wait for
the one day to tell them that
or you can tell them every day and
halloween you just get weird dude
i dressed up as a dragon it was just
guys sucked a couple halloween
dude i was a dragon and got my dick
sucked tail at the back
dick in the front dragon eyes
yeah bro what's up bro why are you doing
that on christmas
dude just because brian gave you a blow
job
after one of you still counts bro still
counts
it still does count i can't do their
dick sucked on christmas too holy you
know what i'm saying like
but it's that time of year when the
other side of the coin is right there
man that there's
halloween is going too far it's like oh
everybody's a [ __ ] now you know
somebody's a battleship
yeah there's like they don't have an ass
on their outfit it's like oh i thought
somebody's like an industrial worker
that sucks dick and you're like what is
this
you know it's just [ __ ] now no you
gotta get creative on halloween
christmas is it's not creative christmas
you can wear whatever red and green
eggnog family on the [ __ ] christmas
that's it basic baddies kids get to have
joy bro jesus freaking christ was born
the
only change we have it doesn't work
that's a fake that's a mate he was not
born
little danny buddha was born or whoever
whatever dude wow i'm not changing my
stance
let's move on all right and we'll love
to get the responses from the list
you [ __ ] see where they yeah pumpkin pie
carving you idiot
christmas so send in your responses to
uh these debates
and we'll we'll do a follow-up episode
as well number two
hey guys my name is christian i'm 25
from livermore california
huge fan of both you guys um but i got a
question for you guys so i got a man bun
and my question for theo is man bun
versus mullet
this isn't a mullet's hockey haircut all
right thanks
thank you christian christian wow so
crazy that was his name
christian wonder who sent that name in
right on the very next question
wonder if it was maybe the lord maybe
the lord
strikes down upon us yeah he goes you
know what theo is right about christmas
yeah king it nope um
listen man but man buns are
we're a fad unless you're a japanese
samurai it's tough to have a man bun
these
but where you can add jewelry though in
a man bun you can have jewels if you're
trying to
hide some [ __ ] in your man bun but if to
to rock a mullet
like back in the day everyone was doing
it but to do it now
i mean that is a big dick energy move
you know what i'm saying because it not
you know you get some [ __ ] for it unless
you're in the inner circle unless you're
a fan of theo or you're in the
circle of fighting the kid and the squad
people are going to celebrate you but
outside in the real world you take heat
for them you think but you yeah
they're coming but i think you can't be
around my kid if you have a mullet like
we had before you came over thanksgiving
we had a huge discussion really should
we allow him in
i went listen i know him pretty well and
every they just kept saying he has a
mullet he has a mullet i know
and we we're torn and then you just
showed up and he just showed him like
well [ __ ] it well mullets just show up
dude you don't expect them dude
a lot of times cancer patients you know
what's wild is when god regrows their
hair
it starts at the very back and grows
along there first oh instant i've never
seen that
and so a lot of you don't know that if
you the first
one of the first steps of beating cancer
first signs you're beating cancer
is your body starts to sprout a mullet
and that's pretty fascinating and that's
that's a plus that's science that's
science and also though
and two people that i like most on this
earth you and dog the bounty hunter
both have [ __ ] mullets both have the
same style dog heads now shout out to
the stylist
that can fly to hawaii cut his [ __ ] fly
here and cut your [ __ ] shout out to him
and then trim about stupid haircut
dude don't even tell me speaking of
pepperoni nipples wow she's got some
garbage bags full of ted
on her dude she has some [ __ ] watto
melons
oh dude i would hide bro i'd hide 6 000
mullets in each tit
dude [ __ ] hide all [ __ ] floppy
discs in her tooth
dude any [ __ ] viruses i had put
between her tits
how many terabytes you think her tits
are [ __ ]
at least seventy thousand bro let you
know
i would keep my i would put her in my
car and keep her to keep all my [ __ ]
cds as a cd changer between her tits
just [ __ ] give me this three and just
reach into her titties and put it in
there
bro if you throw just like a grape
between her tits i bet just
wine comes out her mouth she's really
something else
it's like a black hole you throw
anything at those titties it's just a
black hole just
poof so what was this guy's question
dude oh mullets or uh
man buns yeah dude i think well here
i'll say this one thing that's really in
coming in right now and i've noticed it
and i had this when it was night and i
had long hair in the back in canada you
go to this
it's a hockey haircut in um you know in
san francisco do you go to this it's a
lesbian haircut you know
and it's really like denver it's like a
stepmom haircut is what they call it
yeah like you can go to great clips go
give me the stepmom
yeah like yeah i go hiking a lot yeah i
drive a [ __ ] subaru outback
i shop at eddie bauer give me the step
mom
dude why do low-key most lesbians shop
at eddie bauer they love it right and
they get the vests and the khakis
and a lot of black men are starting to
wear this too and black women have had
this haircut now they'll have a finger
wave on the side they've had this for
years i haven't seen that
the thing is is when i was you know
people say well there
you know a lot of times in the news they
say well people where i'm from don't
like women
we've been wearing their [ __ ]
haircuts since 1970
okay you want to support a woman you go
out and grow their haircut
okay then i want to see the proof
brother i'm going to say
i'm going mullets man i'm not pushing
man buns with this guy man bun is
somebody hiding a mullet into a little
[ __ ]
you know kidnapping a mullet into a
little top piece yeah you're ashamed to
show your true mullet you're you're
worried about what that
the outsider's gonna say i smell it all
day all day
so i guess then that one we agree on we
agree on mullet wow first agreeable
oh my god it's [ __ ] shannon nick in
the same person
and the big brown
[Music]
yo i think you should debate about
ninjas versus samurais
i'm 25 asian
dude baby
[Music]
that's coming from john martino and he
had a number of submissions oh wow
where's he from
it didn't say where's he from dude where
do you think he's from bro
he's from the 11th planet bro he's from
eddie brock from the north sarah
dude from the north pole he come from
underground oh dude that guy
was raised deep in the mountains bravo's
medulla oblongata his parents go first
okay i need that guy's energy that's
punxsutawney john right
oh man that guy is living on a flat
earth
for sure i think we might have just
found our mascot man yeah that's the
mascot
sting let's play your time i want to see
that [ __ ] bad motor scooter
he looks like every character in
groundhog day all in one game
[Music]
and the big brown got a show
it's like thundercats oh i love this guy
i think you should debate
or he's in his mom's closet
one is a sword and one doesn't have a
sword dude both the first and i'll go
have swords bro no you're going ninjas
i'm going samurais yeah
you know why i'm going samurais yeah wow
you don't know
tom cruise was the last samurai he's a
white guy who plays samurai
yeah there's a lot of there's a lot of
people were upset about
it that is why dude decide to infiltrate
as a japanese samurai
i love the movie though and he learned
the ways by the end
real samurai bro what do you mean he
died for that [ __ ] bro two hours it was
two hours they try to convince
complete imbeciles i'm not going to name
names sure but you know since you're
representing that that group right now
yeah that's fine
that john can what was the guy named
john candy martino
no the guy you said tom cruise tom
cruise
thomas cruz yeah thomas cruz is a
ninja dude okay first of all i've seen
tom cruise at the trader joe's one time
dude in brentwood
so definitely not ninja behavior in the
daytime
ninjas eat at night everybody knows that
so fake
second of all wait your argument's
already [ __ ] up you're saying samurai
last summer it's not the last ninja
you [ __ ] no [ __ ] you [ __ ] nascar [ __ ]
it's not the last ninja any the last
samurai
also don't call samurai's ninjas yeah
are you in third grade
everyone calls anything with martial
arts ninja okay
well first of all also ninjas have ninja
stars
which are complete [ __ ] don't like that
star let me know how it goes for you
yeah dude
okay dude you can't
you're doing ninjas you idiot no i'm
samurais bro you're ninjas i'm ninjas
yeah
yes i am and what i'm saying is that
ninjas
first of all samurais carry a heavy
sword bro you know
maybe that sword is slaughter people so
you're not slaughtering dude a lot of
times they don't even show you their
deaths
they'll be trying to get their sword out
of the thing you get hit by a truck
you've ever heard of a samurai
people shot you've heard of samurai
death they have a little sword
in there this should just kill all
arguments they have a little sword right
here on their side
and if they disobey or or or if they
disrespect
the word of the samurai they commit
suicide i don't
swear seppuku is tuning did you know he
was samurai huh i knew he was a [ __ ]
samurai that's
john martino's [ __ ] brother and he
was also a premature baby so a lot of
his ideas we don't know where they're
coming from no bro
samurai samurai the only thing you know
the only thing you got i'm gonna help
you out here
teenage mutant ninja turtles yep besides
that ninjas are full of [ __ ]
well think about this about a ninja
ninjas get up early so do samurais
ninjas sunrise make rice news can read
fast
think about a fact think about a book
and now they're done reading it yeah
ninja you barely even hear him turn the
pages like what the [ __ ] was that the
wind
and it's like nah [ __ ] that's gone
with the wind and [ __ ] chun yan just
absorbed it
you know think about stupid ninja like
the foot soldiers and teenage mutant
ninja turtles can't even hear him
but they suck they never get anything
done they always get beat up they've
never stopped
they can sneak up on people ninjas can
yeah ooh what's up behind you
how about a samurai even though i don't
celebrate their man buns which they rock
but they also have those dope [ __ ]
outfits like that's a whole get up
yeah with ninjas just black okay black
suit it looks like chris deleo's pajamas
the [ __ ] they tie off in the [ __ ]
yeah
it's just dope bro take some effort
ninja doesn't
no effort to tie your [ __ ] whole
outfit one time dude bring up a [ __ ]
samurai ninjas have to wear a
mask dude yeah because they're stupid
look at that [ __ ] oh my
god that's a nice dress dude it's called
a knight it looks like a fan of the new
orleans pelicans that got some freebie
sword because they got to the arena
early bring that guy back up man
yeah look at that [ __ ] dude that looks
like you you're either gonna kill
someone or you're gonna [ __ ]
like there's no two ways about it you're
not just saying you're gonna kill
yourself dude that's a once they do
i'm doing glad they do because they all
need to [ __ ] die bro ninjas are so
much better dude samurais are
real though ninjas can tiptoe better
than anyone who invented tiptoeing look
at that guy
who is that dude that's a samurai bro
yeah you're trying to hide
samurai who are you gonna beat when you
have twelve hundred pounds of [ __ ]
clothes on they're the knights of japan
bro
dude they sure are bro you know the real
color of a samurai
what pink really yep
oh wow let me see it i didn't know that
that's that's real yeah
pink's the the a warrior color in japan
pink it or stinky bro i'm [ __ ]
staying with ninjas on my [ __ ] ninjas
all right samurais bro what else we got
here we go shout out to that human
gopher john martino
john martino our mascot really and
william shadow in february that's what i
want to know that's part of
tony john let us keep us posted yeah
we're on those of our seats
what would you rather watch wnba or
men's college basketball yeah
debate that [ __ ] son okay
i will stand up for you taking women's
basketball
i will do my best to support the wnba
right now
thank you okay i'm taking men's college
basketball
okay okay that's oh that's fine
where can you see though i remember
turning on a wnba game and i was like
holy [ __ ]
latrell sprewell plays for every team i
know and that
and you don't get that you didn't have
wnba on you had
joanna man the movie okay
you thought you were watching the sparks
was actually joanna man that's a movie
that's not real bro but i saw a lot of
wnba players at the airport
and a lot of them were sitting off
paired off in twos and look like they
were secretly trying to
trying to touch each other and i'm not
joking yeah no they suck each other's
tits before now oh
can you even imagine yeah like gatorade
bro how great the dudes do gatorade yeah
they suck each other's tits and ass
have you seen a lot of those post uh
wnba interviews yeah i have
really yeah oh wow i've never seen any
because they
always suck because nobody gives a [ __ ]
after the game dude
stadium is empty yes
seven people on the ground it's their
friends and family going
yeah yeah get them girl yeah
all their fans are basically little
rachel maddows that come
out there and just want to get a picture
with a large black woman because they
didn't
live near any growing up and they feel
guilty they have white
exactly they buy a ticket to the wnba
the [ __ ] la sparta
or the crowds full of old fat white
dudes who just have this
weird [ __ ] oh yeah weird [ __ ]
fetish with
large black women who dunk basketballs
yeah they want that dark fetish
and the thing is you did the only joy in
it
is um there is none theo you're right
the free hot dogs
yeah that's the thing go to a wnba game
you get everything free you get free
rent you get everything they will come
candy yeah you just play you can play
for the team
i coached the other day i wrote up a
play i don't know [ __ ] about basketball
yeah
hey big [ __ ] just stand in the middle
i'm gonna tell you the ball the toledo
mint leaves dude
they have the craziest names horrible
names oh dude
mexico of green chilies the sandinis
cappuccino cups
like what the [ __ ] bro boston bratwurst
and i wish they would just say hey this
is the gay women's basketball league
yeah why not just say hey we're all gay
yeah come get some yeah we're all gay we
play only in west hollywood yeah see if
you can get this [ __ ] now that i would
go like
no [ __ ] this the slogan should be we all
gay
hashtag get this [ __ ] yeah yeah dude
and then i would go and the contest at
halftime is
you have to you have to try to get one
of the player's phone numbers
and you have 30 seconds as a man as a
man yeah you gotta see if you can
somehow
somehow charm them into giving your
number yeah
or and then you gotta see if you can
slide into their dm to send a dick pic
without them
getting upset okay so i i want to say
reverse psychology here
but it sounds like brendan has agreed
that the wnba
is more is more better than college
value no because here's the thing yeah
what here's the thing because i could
figure out what you were doing i could
take a division three player
who's coming off the bench at [ __ ] if
for
college wherever furman pick a school i
don't give a [ __ ]
that kid would score a hundred points
yeah bro
dude i whenever i went to louisiana
state university they had
tons of very lean men or
wnba players and they were good bro
simone augustus was there they were
[ __ ] good
chill swoops a [ __ ] you up really oh my
god or reggie miller's uh
i think cheryl reggie miller's sister
sheryl miller look dude it's reggie
miller but joanna man yeah
do you know they're the same person did
you know that they're twins
but i'm confused because reggie went
gone for a game
then cheryl mills scored a hundred
points sure came out of nowhere and a
half
and a half yeah come on bro that's
reggie
well i'm just the only thing about wnba
is a lot of them will low-key sliding
your girlfriend's dms when they're in
town and try and suck their [ __ ]
oh yeah yeah i know that's why you gotta
you gotta defend
dude you have to defend like a goalie
against i'm choosing i'm picking a half
as
this guy suggested i'm taking the wnba
the good things are you get to see
[ __ ] move fast yeah [ __ ] that noise um
it's like watching ellen play five on
five
i'd rather watch uh men's college
basketball watch [ __ ]
zion williams oh you're picking the
[ __ ] guy
the most guy who could be a woman zion
yeah like the lebron james of college
basketball dude yeah you never know
watch in two years he comes out of the
um
wnba and then wnba is amazing i know so
we both went
now we're talking let's test some of
these boys and see if they really are
you know what they're really planning on
genetically because i'd love to see some
of these beautiful men go
into the wnba some dudes with pretty
faces yeah
and if you want to do diversity put some
men in there put a couple of mexican
guys you know
who never had a shot to play basketball
because they're short yeah they don't
even play with the ladies and i've said
it we get a couple of asians in there
you're one of those times on asian wnba
cham um none chin's upset about it yeah
supports jersey chin has a
[ __ ] season membership to la spark
yeah you know his feelings are hurt you
can't relate to none of them [ __ ]
dude l.a sparks
i thought it was a place to get my
[ __ ] uh my uh tune-up i know
right that's a real basketball league i
thought it was where brandon is shooting
is special
that's freckles bro all right what else
we got yeah let's see some more man
this one's from devron not in here jesus
christ
hey beast thing in the rat king uh it's
devron from australia
much love uh i have a debate topic for
you guys
what do you prefer 80s fashion or 90s
fashion which one is better to you
let us know thank you we're the same
sweater size as me that's cool um
who knows if you don't like bro you have
no clue like i could be five foot two
you have no idea i'll say this for i'm
gonna take 80s fashion and i'll say
taking 80s yep 80s fashion
you got the you got marie francoise your
bow jeans
they were the first jeans you could keep
a knife in on the side 80s fashions the
neck brace
dude before that if you had a bad neck
you had to hold your head up like this
while you walked around
and very alarming people people thought
you were like you know ichabod crane or
some people would even pull their own
hair and hold it up like this to look a
little different
80s fashion also you could um
they had very short shorts on men you
know so you could see a man's leg and
see if he had good blood flow in his
legs
um 80s fashion they had um
they had um i'm gonna destroy this
they had different types of shoes and
hats
oh that's a good one they had different
ones oh that's cool man oh i think 80s
is good
anyways 90s shits on these everyone in
the world knows
90s 80s was awful people die in their
90s everyone
everyone knows in the 80s it was the
worst time for fashion
ever we had zumba pants mc hammer pants
we
had crisscross you had [ __ ] those
black pants pick something white
nope you had looney tunes yep zumba
guess what you had reebok pumps
you had jordan's your jordan's [ __ ]
five six
those are 90s bro jordan ones are ladies
89
really know your [ __ ] bro yeah guess
what you had dope ass hats
you had starter hats starter jackets i
said you had la gear
you didn't say what kind of hats you had
la gear
you had la gear you mean guns dude no
there you could [ __ ] you had the
reebok pumps bro rock pumps
yeah you have people murdering other
people for that yeah they were in their
shoes bro
you could wear you could you had jinko
jeans you could wear your shirt
backwards and look [ __ ] awesome like
criss crops
i'll say this in the 80s marlborough
started their thing where you could mail
in little things from cigarette packs
and get a sweet jacket or bag
nah man that was in the next candy bro
no that's 80s faster
marble oh [ __ ] nope marlborough miles
nick when did that start can you look
that up
dude you had suede jumpsuits you had
[ __ ] uh you're just naming stuff
georgetown no everyone liked it bro your
georgetown [ __ ] hoya starter jacket
you pull over that were sick as [ __ ]
okay those were nice
you had starter jackets well but the
neck brace dude
that was 80s that's when that came out
bro you think of uh gay dudes with aids
and turtles
dude that's the 80s now aids came out in
the 80s and i'll say that that that
wasn't good but he's talking fashion
only what is this
marlboro uh miles came out in the 90s
this me [ __ ] lighting you up in the
90s
[Laughter]
yes i'm just coming with a weak argument
i got to study more and i was alive in
the 80s
i was too bro but the 80s were a bad
time for fashion everyone knows it was
the worst time
here we go the transition period last
one of the day from kyle villarreal
what's up this is kyle it's chris
jonesville texas and i just wanted to
see
if you prefer being a stand-up comedian
or if you'd rather be a rock star
damn that guy feels like i feel like
he's trying to [ __ ] he do bro
he's charming dude i feel like he's
hoping we say rock stars play it again
it slides into our dms and [ __ ] us bro
dude play it backwards and put some
porno music too
hey boys wow you into stand-up or being
a rock star
who wants to go on the road with me and
be a [ __ ] road rat
damn mister steal your girl you play it
oh you want to play yeah sorry buddy
yeah i like his voice
what's up this is kyle from huntsville
texas and i just wanted to see
if you preferred being a stand-up
comedian or if you'd rather be a rock
star yeah panting
god does that guy been drinking calm
brother his hair looks [ __ ]
healthy i agree dude i mean [ __ ] does he
wash his hair in red wine
that [ __ ] was delicious looking wasn't
it nice dude i bet if you lift the back
of his hair up there's just cheese and
meats back there
your [ __ ] looks like barbed wire after
looking at this whatever
that guy's probably rich family do we
grew this out of very
very meek circumstances yeah i agree man
that came from nothing
that came from nothing that came from
the soul of louisiana
that dude was born with a silver spoon
in his mouth oh in his ass
and a head [ __ ] full of gold you know
what i'm saying
uh what was the question though stand up
or rock star
you go first yeah what do you want first
i'm gonna have to what do you say which
one you rather be
i would rather be for me i'd rather be
man i just saw that movie stars um you
talking about rockstar with mark
wahlberg star is born oh no mark
rockstar
mark wahlberg make you not want to be a
rock star really no it looks bad
no it's great dude really fantastic i
thought it looked bad too i never
watched it oh dude i'm telling me too i
didn't see it in theaters but you know
it's one of those tbs movies or tnt
catch it on there amazing bro you seem
like a guy that watches a lot of bad
movies though no no no
they're moving bro
from pepperoni tits on the screen for
three i didn't get a horror and got an
erection because there's a lot of
electricity in the room don't go don't
go don't see boogie night you come in
those [ __ ] tight sweats
these are spoiler alert they [ __ ]
lost movies
hey do you have to get movies cleared by
your sponsor like can you see can you
see spiderman because the female in it
has
a set of tits you know that right uh
there are movies you can see where they
blur out the tits oh okay
but you have to get it like checked off
no no no i watch most of what i want but
it's like i don't can you listen to rap
music
uh i choose not to listen to some of it
but does your sponsor like
stay away from gucci man whatever if
somebody beats their spouse that's when
i quit listening to him
okay so i'm almost out of everybody i'm
basically down to it this year you're
just country music yeah at this point
yeah except for the hoodie and the
blowfish guy
i heard he hits his band mates really
yeah jesus dolphins make me cry
that's what i heard bro it's tough times
dude on the road i bet what did this guy
want to know uh stand up or uh
rock star which one would you rather be
dude i'd be honest man i'd rather be a
rock star you'd rather be a rock star
are you sure you want to go with rock
star actually here's my argument
okay every night imagine being [ __ ]
uh nickelback and you're traveling all
over the goddamn world
singing the same song never made it as a
wise man
never made it is a poor man stealing
next night never
made it as it was man fly 30 000 miles
brazil
never made it as a wise man every night
every [ __ ] night
stand up let's say you want to mix
things up with your set tonight
cool you can mix it up let's say the
next night you want to
go back your old set you can do your old
set you're the [ __ ] you want
you got the freedom to do that banned
they have the freedom to do it well they
don't
they can't if your [ __ ] journey try
playing a new track for everyone uh
what the [ __ ] are you doing hit me with
the [ __ ] i want to hear man
yeah you can't do new [ __ ] stand up you
go on comedy store tonight and do
all new [ __ ] for people that you've
thought of today yeah
and you don't have to depend on six
other [ __ ] you're like oh i got this
song i'm the drummer
okay so you're saying comedy i'll say
this for music
music you get to do music for africa
you get to somehow like aids relief you
get to do age relief you get to do all
kind of relief dude other kind of stuff
yeah you can do music you can play on a
ship
you know you stand up on a ship yeah but
nobody gives a [ __ ] i do a comedy
benefit though see
keep going dude music you can throw a
[ __ ] guitar off the stage when you
get mad
i can throw the mic into the crowd
that's gay i can throw my i can throw my
head
watching a big joke throw a little bitty
mic that's
hooked to a cord that would be tough not
as cool as a guitar
i'll give i could throw the hat into the
crowd bro joe coy does that he throws
his hand the crowd
oh my god dude he catches it in his
mouth
you're gonna kill a 60 year old man
catches it in his mouth that's the
gayest thing i've ever throw a
at least your kid died at a concert
getting hit by a guitar by robert plant
most people wouldn't even sue them and
would just have robert plant sign it
you know what i'm saying at a concert
dude people die all the time get hit by
lightning and [ __ ] like that
the whole place burns down 300 people
die here there's beauty in it there's
[ __ ]
you know there's a there's there's a
soul to it yeah sure the only thing i'll
give you with being a rock
uh singer is you get your dick sucked by
hotter chicks way more often i would
assume
oh think all the groupies that like
groupies as a stand-up
you get some every city you get some hot
some not some with pepperoni nipples
some dude some not you know what i'm
saying
rockstar it's very clear you got those
road rats
and they [ __ ] love your ass dude and
they call me the road rat king you feel
me
rat king baby oh i'm squeezing cheese
across america you know
oh yeah get you that cheddar baby get
you that provolone in your mouth oh dude
i provolone baby with nobody
else you feel me wants that sharp
cheddar in their [ __ ]
who wants that who wants that honey oh
who wants that booty
yeah who wants that i'm dripping down
that ass whoa relax guy
who wants that booty gouda who wants to
suck this dick nectar
whoa whoa dude you're supposed to make
like things that are creative that are
like fun
dude bro first make innuendos all right
bro all right not just saying this
dirty dick neck who wants to who wants
to suck the pollen from my flower
like a b bro like a b bro dude
every as soon as you said that everybody
knows you never got your ged
right there some did
bro just because you were not just
because you were homeschooled
into your late 30s hey dude
we i also played basketball my mother
was a coach um
still i'll say this dude the good thing
about rock stars is
you get to go out and you get to make
people
lose their minds here i'll say this i
think that
music is able to reach more people
because comedy sometimes
people want to think they don't want to
it's all relative isn't it
comedy like mute don't music dope is
dope music like i can appreciate adele
metallica right i can't appreciate like
you know i might have appreciated aziz
and sorry i might not appreciate you
know this like he's not white yeah yeah
there's something
no well i don't know where you're going
with that oh okay just kind of might not
like his style
oh so it's like i'd probably be like oh
maybe i won't listen to this
yeah you know sure um but yeah i guess
uh stand up you got way more it's all
it's all on you you fail or you succeed
all on you
you have to deal with weird managers and
people tend to do this
and this album and this stand up no with
being a [ __ ]
uh rock star you gotta deal with all
these moving pieces stand up
if you're a good stand-up you're going
to [ __ ] you put in the work you know
make it yourself but you don't need to
depend on five other dudes
and this label and let me get this out
[ __ ] no
but musician bro imagine dude you can
musician you have a tour bus with like
four or five of your friends always
going with you because you have to have
them there because they play instruments
well yeah that's what sucks but you
could do a tour bus full of
comedians it's never happened so people
always have it has happened it happened
white
trust me i'd be one of the first people
that asked to be honest
that's what i'm saying i didn't get hit
up yeah well well the white comedy tour
if you've never heard of it
you get the blue comedy tour then the
definitely comedy
life works all i'm saying is you can go
on tour with your boys
dude you name the white guy
def jam the black guy's black the white
guys did it no they didn't blue comedy
tour
jason williams he was a quarterback
[ __ ] sacrifice blue collar
yeah there you go jesus god damn bro
they've done it to your point
[ __ ] two rivers showers that's all we
got
all right man that was fun dude well you
better do your research on fashion and
[ __ ] bands and [ __ ] you got d
destroyed it
you got one debate right
cool guns you have to make the sound of
them get a real gun bro bring a real gun
in here next time hey bro are you
threatening me dude i'm not
going to jail for a long time in this
current culture that's fine
bro i'll just say people listening next
door saying hey the [ __ ]
transitioning russian spy is talking
about bringing a gun tomorrow the only
people that are gone bro
the only people that are supposed to be
next door to hear us is you and chin
and you guys are in here you no not
because they're out there bro
there's nobody there bro it's a hallway
and that guy thinks hiding from somebody
because we go in there at night and
sometimes he's in there and he'll even
have a slide a little bit of pork cut a
pork under the door oh damn bro
so he's definitely that guy i heard he
can't see porn either oh that's why he's
trapped in there
well i'll tell you this the only person
and you could say who won today who
didn't be the only person
that was [ __ ] man enough to get an
erection today in the studio
was your boy right here give it to you
bro so all that porn that's right in
your brain dude i'll show up and get
hard to three [ __ ] boys right here
dude a couple of preemies of guatemalan
over there
big brother showers yeah this is just
[ __ ] gm over here man all right bro
that's the first uh that's the first
episode of king of the sting baby that's
the first episode give me [ __ ] what
works what doesn't yeah
if you have any debates you don't agree
with us or you have better points
[ __ ] upload it and we will uh release
those uh
later in the week yeah i think there's
certainly ways that we can be corrected
and ways that we can be
you know uh have some constructive
criticism uh i think it was good though
i think it was fun man
especially for our first one yeah the
submissions were great thank you guys
very much
amazing yeah thank you for coming thank
you nick uh
only bigger and better from here my
brother yeah i guess it's uh first one
down don't ever dress like that again
but we'll figure it out oh don't you
worry dude
i'm sure i got jeans on some grown man
huh and you got a boner in your kid's
sweat you have one first of all those
are middle school genes
you can't clown you you can't there's
nothing you can say you have
[ __ ] you wear sweats on dude you're a
bully dressed up like somebody to get
beat up by a bully dude you look like
you're transitioning just
like [ __ ] it
[Music]
you